Here we go. Joe. Thank you. Thank you
for being here. Really appreciate it man.
It's pleasure to be here.
It's a fascinating subject.
I've been really looking forward
to talking to you because a,
the conscious mind and how we,
how we evolved our conscious mind,
how we have our conscious
mind. I mean that is a,
one of the more unique things about
being a person. It is. How did it happen?
Oh well it's only a 4 billion year
story as a subtitle, we have some time.
So shall I tell you how
I got short into it?
Where, where I, how I ended up
thinking about that problem.
So I'd been working on how the brain
detects and responds to danger for most of
my scientific career a little bit before
that I'd actually studied consciousness
in these people who have their brain
split apart to control epilepsy called
split brain patients.
So I got interested in consciousness
and also in how behaviors that might be
produced non-consciously uh, affect
what we know about ourselves.
So we see ourselves doing something and
then we kind of consciously build that
into our narrative of what we
are. But a lot of what we do,
we do non-consciously. And when
we interpreted that kind of, uh,
solidifies the fact that you
have a non-conscious system
that's controlling your
behavior, when in fact you, you
didn't do it, but that system did.
So you got to make sense of it and
generate an explanation and narrative.
So that a, that was where I got started
and I tried to figure out, well,
what would it be? Some kinds of
non-conscious systems and said, well,
maybe emotion systems are producing
behaviors that we don't fully understand.
And I started studying
that and ended up, uh,
figuring out how this part of the brain
called the amygdala receives information
about the environment and then controls,
orchestrates all the responses, fight,
flight kinds of responses to
help you protect yourself.
And the, um, you know, after
many years of doing that,
I started asking, well,
how far back does this ability to
detect and respond to danger? Go,
we know that bugs and flies can do that.
And research had been
done showing that, uh,
bugs and flies have certain molecules in
their brain that are important in these
kinds of protective defensive behaviors
and including the ability to learn about
them and store those as memories.
So it's easier to work on
those little tiny, um, uh,
invertebrates than it is to
do studies in a complex brain,
even like a rat brain,
which is pretty complex. Um,
so given that what these people
had discovered about invertebrates,
I and others who were studying mammals
decided to see if the same molecules
might be involved in mammalian
learning. And in fact it was.
So now that raises the question,
you've got the same molecules doing
the same thing, the same molecules,
same genes,
doing the same thing in ancient
invertebrates and in animals like us.
So you ask where back in time is the
ancestor that made that possible?
You know, if we've got the same genes,
either it kind of happens spontaneously
separately are this common ancestor and
indeed there's a common ancestor.
And that goes back to the first organism,
first animal that had a bilateral
Bobbie, which means had left,
right front and a back,
uh, and a top and a bottom.
So it has kind of three dimensional sides.
Before that there were animals
like jellyfish that were radial,
but no, front and back, they just
have the, a top and a bottom.
And before that they're sponges,
which have no front back, top, bottom,
they just kind of randomly
organized. So that's kind of the,
that's the story of animals, sponges to
jellyfish, to these bilateral animals.
So the ancestor, uh, the, the,
the bilateral animal that we're talking
about gave rise to those two lines.
One that became all these invertebrates
like flies and bugs and snails and
octopus and all those things. And
another two animals like us, vertebrates,
all the, um, fish, reptiles,
mammals, birds and so forth.
So those are two separate lines that
inherited these genes that make the memory
and defensive behavior
possible. So we said, well,
how far back they deny it. Does
it stop there? And no, it doesn't.
Because you can find those
genes on through jellyfish.
And then keep going into
single cell organisms.
Now these are like protozoa, uh,
things that give you intestinal,
um, their intestinal parasites
that they can, you know,
give you an upset stomach. And um,
things like amoeba paramecium that
you might've heard of and you know,
biology class in high
school or something. Um,
these have no nervous system and yet
they detect and respond to danger.
They learn about their environment,
they do all these sorts of things.
And where did they come from? Well,
if you go all the way back
to where they came from,
the even simpler kind of organism,
still single cell of course
like bacterial cells.
Now these guys go back
to the beginning of life.
The first cell that ever lived,
some 3.7 billion years ago that gave
rise to the entire history of life was a
bacterial like cell that started dividing.
Now what's interesting,
that cell that started dividing is the
mother of every bacterial cell that ever
lived. So that cells, it's, it's
more like it's re, you know,
that cell is still alive because it's,
they reproduced by cell division.
So that still sell,
just keeps reproducing.
And part of that first cell
ever is still with us today.
And all the bacterial cells that are,
that are around a kind of a mind blowing
thing is it's incredibly mindblowing.
Do we have any idea why the first
cell decided to divide? Well, it,
this, I shouldn't say it's the
first cell that decided to do this.
It's the first cell anterial cell.
It's the first cell that was able to,
to sustain life long enough to give off
offspring that could sustain and sustain
and sustain.
So there were probably lots of experiments
before a kind of cell or kind of
group of cells had the right stuff
to be able to do that. So they,
those others never made it because they
didn't have quite enough of what it took
to be a cell that could do
that. So the first cell, I mean,
it's kind of a hypothetical cell.
It's called Luca the last universal
common ancestor of life. Whoa. Yeah.
And that, so that's about 3.73
point 8 billion years ago. Um,
but he could have been a
bunch of cells, you know,
or a collection of cell cell types,
uh, that, that one of which then,
you know, populated all of life.
The weird thing about life is not just
that it's different and it varies so
much, but that it's, eh, it's
ever-increasing in its complexity. Well,
if you go back to the single cell and
then you come all the way to today to a
person, right? Like what a weird
sort of transformation. You know,
it's dangerous to talk about as if
we're moving towards some kind of goal
intellect, right? Is it
dangerous? We are the goal,
but we're not saying I don't
think we're the go. No, we're not.
We're definitely not.
I've been more and more thinking that
artificial life is the goal. Well,
the, I mean, there's no goal of
life. There's survival. This,
the only goal of every
organism. And that's, uh,
that's what that first sale was able to
do is to generate a set of biological
properties that could still sustain
itself long enough to reproduce.
That's all you have to do. B, you
have to live long enough to reproduce.
And to do that you have
to have energy resources.
So you have to incorporate nutrients.
You've got to balance your fluids.
Otherwise, you know,
you have to keep your eye on straight
or the cell will get too big and explode
or get too small and collapse.
You've got to thermoregulate cause all
of these things depend on the right kind
of internal temperature and you
have to reproduce. Those are the,
the survival requirements of a cell.
But there are also the survival
requirements of a human.
So the same things that bacterial cell
has to do to live through the day and
create a species is exactly what we
do every day. To reproduce ourselves.
We have to eat, drink,
defend against danger, uh,
incorporate nutrients and balance
fluids and ions that way, uh,
defend, you know, reproduce. And so
that was the mind blowing thing. See,
I wrote the whole three quarters of the
book as a scientific journalist cause I
didn't know any of this in this
stuff. I had to just learn it.
And there's a lot of fun, but it
took a long time. Imagine when,
when you think about the
original Luca and then human,
do you ever try to extrapolate?
Do you have ever tried to like keep the
process rolling in your mind and see
where, where's this going to go? Oh yeah.
So the end of the book I paint a not
so rosy picture of what was going well.
Yeah, but, so that, let's talk about
the end of the book. So, okay. Um,
I, you know, say, okay, well our,
we have these two kinds of, of, uh,
significant experiences in our lives
that uh, that occupy the human mind.
One is the kind that we can
call an awareness of facts.
You know,
this thing is here and the
other is what we might call,
um, a self-awareness where I, it's,
it's me that is aware that
that is a bottle. So that's,
that's a higher level.
And that is what appears to
be unique to the human mind.
The ability to represent the self
as a subject. In other words,
to have these subjective experiences
that have a personal past.
It's not just the past,
but your past you lived at and a personal
present and a potential future that
you can imagine different scenarios
of you existing in, in the future.
So that requires a, I mean that's
called auto Noetic consciousness.
The ability to, to self know
about where you are in time.
And it depends the,
this is an idea that was proposed
by a guy named [inaudible],
a very distinguished
psychologist who's a retired now.
But his idea was that
the unique aspect of,
of the human mind is mental time travel,
the ability to project ourselves
in the past, present and future.
And without that kind of consciousness,
we're limited to kind of factual
information. Something is there, you know,
that might, I might be able to say, Oh,
food is there or drink is there
or a sexual partner is there,
but not necessarily that I want
that food. I want, you know,
you might have a kind of
biological urge towards it.
Now from the outside it
looks like everything we do
is intentional and willful.
So I think I'm controlling my behavior.
You think you're controlling yours?
I see you do something that I
might've done in a similar situation.
I think you intentionally control that.
We see a dog doing something that
would be similar to what we do.
We think we know why the dog is doing
that because it had some intention.
But the fact is if we start taking
these things apart in the brain,
we see that the systems that control very
simple behaviors are not the ones that
are doing all this high level conscious
thought. Take the example of a,
the area I've worked on for all these
years, which is threat detection.
Um, now this part of the brain called
the amygdala is key to the detection and
response to threat and the kind
of basic sense. Um, you know,
a threat comes up, you freeze it,
there's a snake for example. Um,
now it's all because of that.
It's been assumed that the reason you
freeze is because you're afraid and
therefore that the amygdala is also
making the fear because they make doula
experiences the fear and that's
why you produced the response.
But for the longest time and
throughout most of my career,
I've said the amygdala does not
consciously experience fear.
And yet my work is been
used to kind of sell and uh,
and defend this idea of the
Migdal is the brain's fear center.
And I think that's completely wrong. Why
do you think it's been misinterpreted?
It's a long, complicated
story, but you know, it's
partly, it's my fault
because I was not, uh,
as vigilant as I should have been when I
was describing it to see what I did was
I,
I would talk about the amygdala
as a non-conscious state of fear,
non-conscious, implicit fear. Um,
and I would say that, well,
the neocortex is where we consciously
experienced fear and those are separate,
but that was too complicated. You know,
the journalists kind of
ignored it and it was just,
it just became the Migdal
is the brain's fear center.
Even the scientists ignored it because,
you know, we were studying and you know,
I kind of gave up after one study. Okay.
We talk about it in terms of fear, um,
because you know that there
was a lot of money to be, um,
directed towards research
if you're studying fear and
how you could treat that.
But I think it's, you
know, it's been kind of a,
a wrong path because it's led to the
development of medications that don't
really work. So all the big
companies are getting out of,
of the anti-anxiety business anti fear
business because people still feel
fearful or anxious when they take them.
You mean like Xanax things
along those lines? Yeah.
Companies are getting out of the Xanax
business. Um, benzos annex. Yeah.
I mean they're not there either that
or repurposing them for other purposes,
you know, but so what happens is you,
the way these things, you
know, the, these things,
the basic drugs were
discovered in the 60s, uh,
almost accidentally in some cases, you
know, not rather than by some hypothesis.
So they only thing that's been discovered
since then is more versions of the
same thing with, you know,
slightly fewer side effects.
But there's been no new discovery of a
new kind of drug that's going to help
people. And why is that? Well,
the way the drugs are discovered
is that take a rat or mouse,
put it in a challenging situation,
give it some different medications,
and the ones that make the animal less
timid in those situations is assumed to
make the animal less fearful.
And that's why he's less timid.
So when you give it to a person,
they should be less fearful.
But what you find is say a person with
social anxiety might find it easier to go
to the party. They're less timid, but
still anxious while they're there.
And the reason is that we now know is
that damage to the amygdala in a person
doesn't necessarily also
eliminate the feeling of fear.
It gets rid of the body
responses, but not the feeling.
So it was a misunderstanding
of what behavior can tell us.
We treat behavior as if it's
an ambassador of the mind,
but behavior is really a tool of survival.
That goes back to those first cells that
ever lived who had to defend against
danger.
Bacterial cells move in there in the
water and then they come across like you
know, a gradient of some chemical that's
a toxin. As soon as they detect that,
they bounce away and go in a
different direction. If they are gone,
if they find a gradient of something
that is a nutrient they keep going in and
absorb it.
So they have the ability to detect
what's useful and harmful in their lives.
These are not, these are
not there for psychology.
They're simply there to
keep the organism alive.
And many of the behaviors that persist
throughout the whole history of life are
like that.
They're there because each of the
cell and cells in the body has to,
you know, do all these
things to stay alive.
And so the organism as a whole has to
do it as well. Defend against danger,
incorporate nutrients, balanced
fluids, Dermer, regulate, reproduce.
So these are survival
tools, not mind tools.
Now we can use our mind in conjunction
with these things and because we can,
we conflate every time we're freezing
in the front of a snake to the fact that
the fear is what's causing it. But
the fear is a separate process.
It's the awareness that that
stuff is happening to you,
the awareness that that stuff is
happening to you. So no self, no fear.
Awe, that's my tee shirt.
That's my merge on the book.
Now, how do things like Xanax work? What,
what's the mechanical
process? Okay, so the a,
that's a part of the class of drugs
called benzodiazepine and they,
um, will they bind to
receptors in the brain.
The brain has receptors for
all kinds of, uh, chemicals.
And many of these things are
things that exist in nature.
And what the dilemma that they bind to
is a receptor called the GABA receptor,
which is the major inhibitory
transmitter in the brain.
So when you have a benzodiazepine
binding to a GABA receptor,
what it's going to do is increase
inhibition. So the, you know,
the kind of simple reason why those
things can help is they kind of inhibit.
So they tone down brain a bit.
And so things that would normally
trigger a response, no longer trigger.
So it's like increasing the threshold
for something to bother you in a sense.
And a lot of people enjoy that with
alcohol and not supposed to. Well,
alcohol also attacks those receptors.
So it's like you get double the effect,
right? Is that why they tell people don't
have Xanax? Cause you can, you know,
if you, if you take a lot of
sandbox and drink a lot of booze,
you can Odie or you could
just say crazy things.
Not totally be aware. Do you
remember that story about a woman?
She was a, I believe she was a
publicist and she got on a plane,
she's flying to Africa and
she said, I'm going to Africa.
Hope I don't get AIDS. Just
kidding. I'm white. LOL.
She thought she was just being funny and
you laughed and she landed in Africa.
That's a bit of a surprise.
Do you know the story? No,
but there are other stories on this.
This was one of the original stories of
someone ruining their entire life with
just putting, uh, you know,
one little tweet online.
She thought she was being funny. Like she,
she would say a bunch of snarky
things like that. A bunch of funny,
trying to be fun. Right. Um,
but she was on Xanax and
drinking and woke up, uh,
w completely oblivious and her life had
been destroyed. Yeah. She was fired.
You know,
she was a social pariah and I'm pretty
sure that was Xanax and alcohol that she
was blaming it on.
Yeah. Well, you know, these
are powerful drugs and so,
you know, back to how
they work and they work.
So a drug like that,
all of the drugs that we
take go to the entire body.
They don't, they're not
able to just, you know,
find their way to one little spot in the
brain and do their trick. This, this,
you know, talk about
magic bullet, a bullet,
drugs that might be able to be
targeted for specific circuits,
but that's a fantasy at this point.
So if you reduce inhibition
in the entire brain,
yes, you might reduce, you know, anxiety,
but you're also going to change a lot of
other things. So you're gonna make, um,
um, for example,
forethought and a ability
to reign in things like the,
the stuff the woman was saying, uh,
more difficult because they're attacking
the prefrontal cortex where you have
some inhibitory control over behavior. Um,
they're going to alter your ability to
retrieve and store memories and to be,
to attend to things. And, um, you know,
to the extent that these drugs have
a, a positive effect on some people,
uh,
it's been said that part of the reason
is that it's kind of a general blending
of emotion. It's not an antianxiety drug.
It's just kind of the
dulling of everything.
And you get anxiety anti-anxiety
as, as a part of that.
But if we want to understand
how to do better, um,
we have to, you know,
figure out what the brain circuit
that's really making us anxious is,
and not just what's
making us, you know, not,
not toning down to everything.
It's kind of like, you know,
you go to a restaurant, the
music's too loud, somebody says,
please turn it down. So they
turn it down a little bit.
The music stays the same. So the same
song, but it's not as annoying, you know,
because you've turned the volume down.
And I think that's what a lot of what
these medications can do is turn the
volume down a bit or turn it up. You
know, depending on what you're doing.
Correct me if I'm wrong, but isn't
there some sort of a Slingshot of fact,
like after you take these things and your
anxiety is ramped up afterwards? Well,
it can be a rebound. The fact
that it can also be kind of a,
a lot of people next day feel
depressed, know because they're just,
the stuff is out of your system and
just come to the, you know, if you take,
it's kind of like taking sleeping pills,
things like Ambien are of the same general
category of drug then so diazepines
and so you get this
hangover the next day. Okay.
So it's just a physiological
response to the medication.
It's not that if you
alleviate some anxiety,
then the anxiety wants to come back even
stronger. So I, you know, I've often,
I've proposed and in my
previous book that, uh,
we each have an anxiety set
point that, um, you know,
that let's say you're worried about
something and all of a sudden that gets
resolved. I just makes room for
the next thing to work with. So,
you know, we each have kind of fill that
void because our brain is, you know,
we've developed a brain that has a certain
kind of set point for everything it's
doing and that just makes room for,
you know, to fill that, fill that up.
If you're an anxious person, you
probably will always be somewhat anxious.
So there's no magic bullet
that's going to take that out.
What do you have to do is
attack the process from
knowledge of how it all works.
And that requires that we have a more
sophisticated understanding that then is
possible from simply observing behavior
because behavior does not tell you
necessarily what's on the mind.
Behavior tells you how the, the,
the brain has responded. But you
know, just to go back to the,
the fear thread example, um,
when let's say I bring you into the
laboratory and show you a picture of
something like a blue square.
Uh, my colleague Liz Phelps,
who used to be at NYU, who's now at
Harvard, did experiments like this. Uh,
and every time the blue
square would come on,
the person would get a
mild shock to their finger.
And so then she would
present the blue square.
Subliminally that means, you know,
really quickly with the, you know,
something that follows
at the kind of mass that,
and that prevents the information from
getting into the conscious mind. Uh,
and so the person says,
I didn't see anything,
but if you put the person in
an imaging machine, FM, Ori,
and, uh, image, what's happening
that stimulus, that threat,
the blue square gets to the
amygdala, turns it on, the heart,
begins to race, palms are sweating.
Um, but the person has no fear.
The person doesn't know it's
there and doesn't experience fear.
The amygdala is not about fear. It's
about detecting and responding to danger.
In order to be afraid.
That has to reach your conscious mind
so that you can experience it as a state
of this auto Noetic consciousness
that we're talking about.
Self involved consciousness. That's
hard for people to separate. Yeah. Well,
but the, that there's a, a
physical response with that.
Your minds aren't aware of it.
Right. But when you understand that,
that's why you become to understand that's
why the medications are not working.
They're targeted to work on these
underlying systems in rats or mice.
But that's not where we are
experiencing our anxiety. But these,
these medications are very profitable.
Right. And people enjoy it.
Millions of prescriptions get written
up. I'm just going to phase those out.
They'll probably, you know,
they're probably all going off patent
and because the company can't find
anything new,
they're not going to keep pursuing it
because it's not going to be a profit
anymore. But don't people
still want them? I mean,
it seems like that's a really
popular medication. Yes.
It'll be like they'll go to, um,
you know, they'll become, uh,
you know,
generics and people will be able to get
them for less money and they'll just do
with whatever they want. Yeah. Off
label, whatever. Yeah. I mean it's,
you know, it's, I do
think that for example,
the drugs that are available
do help people because it's
important to reduce the
behavioral timidity and the physiological
arousal that goes with that.
Cause if you don't treat
that, then the conscious
mind will be reactivated
by those responses.
If you only treat the
conscious mind, then uh,
the physiological stuff will
bring the conscious stuff back.
Everything will bring back
their everything else,
unless you treat the whole
system and you have to do that,
you have to understand the system and
we've just misunderstood it I think for so
long. I have a friend who,
he takes it every day.
It takes Xanax every day and he says
he needs it. It says without it,
he's just a mess. Well, you know,
whatever gets you through the day,
I guess, you know, it's, I'm not a
therapist. I'm not like advocating that.
I know. I understand, but
from your perspective,
from an understanding of the human mind
and all the systems that are at work,
it seems like that's really not the
way to do it. Yeah. I mean it's,
you know, I'm sure that that's, you
know, in a sense, maybe that's a,
his crutches
were to get through the day and, um,
he's come to believe that he needs that
much like an alcoholic believes they
need to drink. Yup. Yeah. Um, but I'm
not calling him and you know, well,
I'll call him. He does
like to drink too. Yeah.
But he's a great guy. Uh, these, uh,
these systems that are in place and the,
all of the various things that have
gotten us to 2019 is a human species.
When you study anxiety and you study
fear and all these different things is,
are,
are we experiencing high levels of it
because there's not as much real physical
danger as our ancestors experienced.
And it's almost like we're looking for
it when it's not necessarily there.
Like we're, we're programmed to
be able to deal with it. Yeah.
That's a good point. Um, I
hadn't thought of it that way,
but I think that's a good way to
think about it. I mean, you know,
the philosopher Kierkegaard said that
anxiety is the price we pay for the human
ability to choose. And this is where
our auto Noetic consciousness comes in.
Our ability to,
to think of ourselves as having a
past and the future and to be able to,
to plan and choose in
the future. You know,
he said it started with Adam making the
first choices of human in the garden of
Eden. And that was where
it all began. Um, so,
and our ability, you know, you can
rephrase that statement by saying,
our ability, um, to choose is
what allows us to be
anxious because that is, uh,
what anxiety is a worry
about what we have. We are,
we're going to make the
right decision. You know,
how can we deal with this
thing that's coming up?
It's a worry about the future and the
ability to think about the possibilities,
right? Like what could go
wrong? What could go right?
Am I doing the right thing? And then to
contemplate all those various choices.
Right? Anxiety. Yeah.
So like, you know, you,
you're walking through the woods
as a snake, you might freeze,
but almost instantly,
that fear that is generated by you
freezing and seeing the snake, um,
morphs into anxiety, you know, will
the snake bite me if it bites me,
will I get to a doctor? Will
we have the anecdote if I die,
what will happen to my family? And you
know, that's worry, that's anxiety.
So these are,
they're kind of separate fears
about a danger that's present.
Anxiety is about one that hasn't
happened yet. Almost always.
As soon as you're afraid, that makes
you anxious about what's gonna happen.
And then there's general existential
angst. The, the, just the, the,
the life itself. Existence is just a wad.
Is this what, yeah.
And all of that is due to, um,
our prefrontal cortex, our
ability to conceptualize, to,
uh, you know, imagine
things that, that have never been
imagined before. To create art,
to build, create
architecture, build buildings.
Imagine going to the moon,
designing an instrument to do that and
actually pulling it off and make sure it
could get back.
All of that is something that our special
kind of consciousness, uh, enables.
But it has a dark side, which is,
it also allows us to be incredibly
selfish and self centered and narcissistic
and to, uh, support
tribes and groups. And,
you know, uh, unless we, I mean,
I think that the world survives best
when it's either completely isolated,
all the cultures are isolated or if we
could also somehow be together in a more
unified way because of the
direction we're going now,
where each country is isolating itself,
but it's still so entangled with all
the others is a recipe for disaster.
Is this because we evolved
essentially without longterm travel?
I mean,
we kind of evolved to stay in whatever
area of the resources we're in when we're
hunters and gatherers.
And then somewhere along the line somebody
figured out boats and how to get on a
horse. And then the next thing
you know, you're visiting people.
I think it's more about, um, you know,
we have a special kind of inquisitiveness
that we can because we can mentally
model the next step and
plan what are the options,
you know, try to anticipate the, uh,
the problems that are going to come
up and take those steps. Um, and,
and that's a pretty special thing,
but it also allows us to plan
and a kind of devious way where,
you know, me or my group
is going to benefit and uh,
if mine benefits,
I don't want the other one to benefit
cause we got to keep everything separate.
So it's, you know, consciousness. Our
kind of consciousness is, are, are,
you know, greatest achievement,
but also probably our worst aspect.
Oof. But it's, Hm,
but it's what makes us human.
It is imagining humans with no
consciousness is impossible.
There's no way to go in that
direction. That's so is,
is the key to this
thing as the human race?
Is it managing our consciousness
of perhaps maybe work like yours?
Giving us the tools to understand what
are the mechanisms involved that maybe
that can help us sort of
navigate our biological cool
traps. And maybe, I mean,
I think it's, you know,
certainly we don't, I think the, I mean,
I have no idea what your position on,
uh, climate changes.
But, uh, personally I,
that things are happening and
something needs to be done.
That's clearly things are happening
and that, you know, there was,
I read a couple of editorials, uh,
probably in the New York times or
something a couple of months ago.
One was about how, yes, the, you know,
things are changing and, uh,
we have a right to worry. But,
you know, we shouldn't worry
about the earth as a famous quote,
his guy as a tough bitch.
So the earth will survive.
But the configuration of life on it is
unlikely to continue to be the same under
those conditions. The more
that everything changes,
the conditions of life change
and the first things to go. Um,
and this is what happened to the dinosaurs
are large energy demanding organisms
because as the conditions
change, um, you know, the,
the climate that we've lived in,
we've succeeded because we were able
to benefit from that kind of climate.
But as the climate begins to change,
archine is not gonna be able to succeed
as well because those conditions are,
you know, the waters arising,
the desert, uh, expanding.
All of these things are happening
and it's just not going to be, um,
yeah, species don't last that long.
Know a few million years and they go,
so our time may be, we've
only been around for what,
300, 400,000 years and something, well,
it depends on what we call wheat,
but the Neanderthals were around
quite a bit longer than that. Yeah,
they're not here anymore.
So we don't have a, I mean,
I think that we can use
our minds to try and,
you know, help us get through this,
but that's only gonna work if
we can do that collectively.
That's the scary part.
We have to work together collectively
as a world because these are not local
issues. These are global
issues. Yeah. And that is,
how does that get locked, you know,
especially getting other
countries like China to comply.
It's small successes.
I mean like auto companies
deciding, well we need to,
you know,
reign in the ambitions and
there's probably a profit
motive a underlying that at
some point. Sure. And people
are conscious. There's
green dollars, right? Right.
Like you wanna like when,
when you think about technological
achievements and you think about the,
the conscious mind and the ability
to create and the creative process,
do you envision the possibility of some
sort of a technological solution to a
lot of the problems that we're facing?
I think it has to be a social solution.
Social. How so?
We have to wait,
we have to figure out how
to balance this worldwide.
It can't, this,
we can do whatever we want in this
country if we could do what we want.
But you know, if, uh,
if even if we were the best country
in the world for the environment,
that wouldn't solve the problem. You
know, it's a worldwide problem. You know,
Amazon forest that's affecting
a lot of people. You know,
it's just not a,
it's not a simple thing that
one country can solve, right.
But if one country takes steps and imposes
some sort of a technological solution
that pulls carbon from the atmosphere,
that does enhance some sort of a
cooling process to bring homeostasis,
to bring some sort of a,
like generally agreed upon
state of the environment,
if that's technologically
possible, I mean,
that's going to come out of the
creative mind. Right. Well, you know,
I don't want to go too far off into my
not area of expertise like climate and
saw labs. I just think there's,
I think of it from the kind of the social
perspective and what our brains are
contributing, but I don't want to,
I don't think I can really address
the details of all that. Right.
But even like socially, if
we did address it socially,
we're still gonna have to deal with
the actual physical limitations of the,
just the environment that we live in and
what we've done and how to somehow or
another mitigate it.
Yeah, I agree. Yeah. So,
but yeah, so I think, you know,
creators coming along and trying to
find technical solutions. That's great.
When you analyze the human mind and
knowing what you know about the thought
processes and the way
people think and work.
When you see people in denial of climate
change and when you see people that are
so enamored with the concept of capitalism
and big business that they don't
really think that it's a big deal or
they want to deny that it's a big deal so
that they can continue short term
profits. Right. What does that,
like those mechanisms like wa watching
that take place in the monkey mind,
what do you, what are you thinking
when you see that happen with humans?
You know, I don't think it's
simple. Um, it's not simply
denial of climate change
[inaudible] for climate reasons.
I think there's a lot of social,
you know,
within certain groups there is social
stigma for being pro-environment. Yes.
And so it's, um, tribal, tribal. It's,
it's uh, people, yeah.
People cling together and it's a
kind of form of self protection, um,
that by identifying a set of
issues that we all can agree upon,
um, because they're kind of dictated
top-down in a sense that, um, our,
our thing and then that thing
is somebody else's thing.
So yeah, that's a weird
aspect of being a human
being, right?
These tribal identity things
where if you're in this group,
you must be pro choice, right? If you're
in this group, you must be pro-life.
You must be anti-war,
you must be pro second amendment knowing
there's very little deviation and that
that's left drive. That's everything.
I mean that, that belief systems,
rigid belief systems, uh, you know,
part of, uh, just part of being,
and when you look at politics and
you know, that these belief systems,
when do you find it odd that we have
these like sort of polar opposites or at
least left right? Choices, red,
blue choices that we've limited
ourselves to these very distinct tribes.
Right? And that's, yeah, I think that's
unfortunate, but that's where we are.
Is there a way out of that?
I do know that political science
just has to take that one.
Now we're going down a weird road.
What do you think is the source of
creativity like somewhere along the line?
I mean, and we've seen it, right?
I mean there's some speculation and
scientists have sort of generally agreed
that some monkeys are in the stone
age that some primates are in.
What would be considered stone-age.
They're starting to use tools,
they're starting to use sticks and it
is a famous photograph that I love of an
orangutan. Where are we
going to get a copy of that?
We should get that orangutan with
a spear. We'll make a note of that.
There's a crazy Orangutang image of an
orangutan holding onto a branch and then
spear fishing. It's amazing.
And apparently he had seen humans do it.
So that's where he learned
the behavior imitation. Yes.
But still that is a primate using
a weapon to try to spear fish.
Look at this photo. Isn't that incredible?
Nice. I mean, that is incredible.
That's like really thoughtful and
skillful and the way he's hanging.
I mean, my goodness, look at
that. I've, I love that picture.
That picture is amazing. Yeah. Now this,
the creativity that allows you to
get food when you couldn't get food,
allows you to escape from
environmental conditions,
allows you to escape from predators.
All these things are awarded by the
continuing of your genetics, right?
So, but there are other
things that come into play.
One of the special days
that, uh, that came along,
I think as a byproduct of having language
and by language I don't mean words,
but what language did but what was
required for language to come out of the
brain,
which is the development of a cognitive
sort of architecture in our brain that
allowed all kinds of, um,
mental jumping around. So for example, um,
for most animals to learn, you know,
who to trust and who not to
trust and what some, what,
who's what in any given situation,
who's going to do what to whom by
just looking around, they have to
go through trial and error, learning it,
see the experience, all of that a lot.
But the human mind can simulate,
create a mental model and instantaneously
make those kinds of predictions.
On the basis of very
limited information. Um,
and this is based on something,
well w w the relation to languages
that syntax gives you those kinds of,
uh, options because you can,
you know, you have, um, um,
a past,
present future States that can be related
to you and to others and so forth.
And personal pronouns are very
important in terms of, uh, me,
I mine you years that those, the,
the point when those come in and a child
is the first point when I think self
awareness can fully be tested
and shown. Um, you know,
some people say, well, they have it,
but they just couldn't express it.
Others say no,
but the arrival of the pronoun personal
pronouns are very important in the
child's development of a
sense of self. But anyway,
so language changes, uh,
the brain changes the cognitive
architecture of the brain and allows for
something just to throw out a technical
term, hierarchical relational reasoning,
just the ability to think across
kind of conceptual categories, um,
laterally and horizontally. Uh,
so that information you
can just jump around.
And that's kind of what creativity is.
The ability to just jump around in middle
space and come up with something by a
unique combination of
those things. Do you,
do you think that there's variation
in terms of the types of languages like
Chinese versus Spanish versus that they
allow you to interface with the world in
a different way because the language is
structured very differently? I
think that's absolutely right.
But I don't know if enough about other
languages to say exactly how. I think,
I think it was Malcolm Gladwell.
I think it was the outlier.
So they discussed this like the
limitations of certain languages. Uh,
in terms of, uh, pilots was
that Gladwell think it was, uh,
well they were, they were, they were
discussing how a Korean airlines,
because they have sort of a
hierarchy of, uh, you know, the,
the way you're supposed to treat the
upper levels of management and then that
they had to force these pilots to all
speak English so that they didn't have
this hierarchy, like the,
this presumed hierarchy of being able
to address situations that planes had
crashed because co-pilots
were in their place.
They were put in their place.
And you weren't allowed to address pilots
and that once they had switched over
to English that the language,
like there's so many different versions
of dealing with your boss or someone
who's an upper level person that there
are so many different ways that you were
supposed to address them.
And they had eliminated all
that by using English. Yeah.
And it made me think like,
just using different styles of language,
the way human beings communicate here
is very different than the way people
communicate. Say, you know, in
some African countries, right,
that we have these different styles of
interpreting the world around us and
those in turn have a profound effect on
the way we sort of interface with the
world. And I think that's
definitely right. So it's, you know,
essentially interesting to think
about emotion and language.
So it's often said that an emotion like
fear is universal across the world,
but I don't think that's actually
correct. What's universal is danger.
And the way fear is interpreted by
different cultures is obviously different.
I mean, different, uh, the Asians
have a different kind of a, um,
perspective on fear. Every culture
has their own perspective on fear.
So if it's fear is the, you know,
the kind of cultural assembly that you
have in your brain in response to danger.
So every culture has to
have a language of fear,
but not because fear is universal
because danger is universal
and what they interpret as
danger is different. Right.
And fear for one person, something could,
could create fear whereas
for another person,
the exact same situation would not, right.
Depending upon their personal experiences
and maybe even their genetic makeup.
Well, yeah, I mean, you know,
genes contribute. So we, uh,
every part of our brain is under some
kind of genetic influence. So every,
for example,
the amygdala will be genetically kind of
slightly more wrapped up in one person
than another. So a little
more sensitive to danger.
And so that person might be responding
more to danger in part because of genes,
but also may be because of
experiences that they've had. Uh,
and so then the conscious mind is
seeing those responses and starting to
conclude, Oh, I'm an
anxious, fearful person.
And that all of that information gets
collected in what's called a fear schema,
which is a body of knowledge of everything
you know about danger and including
the way you react, you react
to danger, and you're, uh,
just you know who you
are in terms of danger.
And so whenever you encounter danger,
that schema is what's
called pattern completed.
So presence of a threat in the world
is enough to go into your brain and
activate those memories about
danger that give you, uh,
in a non-conscious representation. You
know, an activation of this fear scheme.
That is what then bubbles
up into consciousness.
That's your experience of fear is what
has been activated in your fear schema.
Knowing what you know,
and then watching whatever anxieties
or fears may play out in your own mind.
Is that, for lack of a better term, a
mind fuck for you? I know what I mean.
Well, I mean, studied this so
much and then you're a human.
So I assume you have the same anxiety
as a lot of anxiety that we all do.
And cheerfully, it helps to some extent.
So I used 1996 I published a
book called the emotional brain.
And few years later I started
finding out from therapists that, um,
the, uh,
a lot of patients were reading the
book with their therapist and they were
saying that it was really helping
them understand why, you know,
how different things were
happening, that the, uh,
the amygdala was causing them
to react in certain situations,
but their fear was their conscious
understanding of those reactions and those
were not the same thing. And that
separation helped them, you know,
navigate their own situation and in a
situation of danger, separating out,
okay, that's my body
is responding this way.
My mind is responding this way and these
are two separate things I need to work
on and control.
Have you studied various ways that
people mitigate anxiety and fear like
meditation and yoga and all
these different things that
sort of change people's
States? I mean, I haven't, I haven't
studied it myself, but I'm a,
I have researched it a bit. Uh, I've,
I tried to do meditation myself
because I think it's the,
probably the most direct and effective
way in the moment to, you know,
sitting in the room outside waiting
for, just had my hat and sunglasses on.
Just trying to chill out, meditate
a little bit, get ready for you.
[inaudible] do you do
that on a regular basis?
It's hard to maintain it cause life gets
busy and it seems like the hardest time
to do it is when you need
it most, right? Yeah.
I think it's one of those things like
hygiene or you sort of have to say,
well it's hard to take a shower then
you have to take a shower. Don't stink.
You have to brush your teeth, you
get cavities, you have to meditate,
you'll go crazy. Yup. It's perfect,
but that's the way it should be done.
I think that is what, so when
you examine those kinds of tools,
like tools that people have
sort of imagined or created
S to sort of in some way
alleviate anxiety or
enhanced perspective, do you,
do you spend much time dwelling on the
creation of those things and what's going
on there? Uh, what do you
mean by the creation? Well,
there's like a human had to
figure out how to meditate.
A heart person had to
figure out these modalities,
these different ways to
sort of interface with.
So let's take that from, uh,
take that to
the nature of most approaches
to fear and anxiety today.
Um, hold this, hold off the
meditation part slightly. Okay.
So we have in a psychopharmacology,
some major line of attack and also, um,
what's called cognitive
behavioral therapy, which is a
Rose as a form first called behavioral
therapy because it came out of the
behaviorist movement, which said there's
no consciousness, you know, that,
that the human is a stimulus response, uh,
organism that is based on a history
of reinforcement with certain kinds of
situations. Um,
so behavior therapy was about using
Pavlovian or opera conditioning to change,
um, how the brain would respond to
threats and how people would act in those
situations. Um, it wasn't
about the mind at all.
It was all about behavior and
then cognition was added to that.
So that became cognitive
behavioral therapy. But again, the,
the cognitive change was used as a way
of changing behavior because so much
emphasis has been placed on,
uh, behavior in our culture,
including in the drug therapy world.
It's all based on changing measurable
things like behavior and physiology.
And that I think that that's why all
of these things in some sense have not
worked out as well as
we would like, you know,
the best in the best medications.
In the best CBT trials.
We'll give you like 75%
record of, of help in a group.
That's pretty great though, isn't it?
Jim still got 25 to 10 but I, yeah,
but you also have to extract
out the placebo effect.
And in many of these, uh, uh,
drug studies, for example,
depressive anti-depression drugs, the
placebo placebo effect is, you know,
only the, the drug effects only slightly
better than the placebo effect. Well,
when you have cognitive behavioral
therapy, there's, I mean,
you're actually going for the placebo
effect, right? I mean you're trying to,
nothing wrong with let's say
both back in that sense though,
you are trying to sort of, you're,
you're trying to use some sort of
strategy with your mind in therapy,
whether it's meditation or what are you
doing? You're trying to enact change.
Right? And if that changes enacted,
there's not a pill involved. Right.
So it is kind of like the same mechanism
that's involved in a placebo effect.
You, your mind is creating
this new change. Yes.
And so, but the question is a person that
goes through the motions but
doesn't get the therapy right.
How much are they changed by
simply by kind of going through it?
It just so many variations with humans
or I'd like to find out like are they
lazy, are they self destructive?
And why is that the case?
Like maybe all of the above, all
the, yeah, whenever you have,
I think 75% amazing.
Yeah. Can you consider,
if you have a group of
people, what are the odds?
If you have a group of a hundred people,
what are the odds of 25 of them are going
to be lazy. Pretty good, right? Yeah.
Pretty. I,
I would bet I'll ton of money at 25%
of those people don't do what they're
supposed to do all the
time. Right. So you know,
you're right. But I think the issue
is from a scientific point of view,
we need to know exactly what really works,
what's different from placebo. Right?
So that we can see what to build
upon for medication, for medication,
for cognitive therapy as well.
But the therapy thing is so strange
to be because you put, okay,
maybe we're using the wrong word with
placebo because placebo is a word for a
medication that has a
psychosomatic effect. Right? Well,
it's the control group that doesn't get
the treatment so that you get that in
not really doing anything physiologically,
but your body is interpreting it
as medicine and saying, all right,
change is coming and then the change
comes. Right. And that is a real thing.
But when you're thinking about
cognitive behavioral therapy,
you're thinking about using techniques
and strategies to change the way you
think and behave though. So the,
the concept of the placebo effect
doesn't really apply there.
Well you have to have a control
group right in the study.
You have to have randomized
control in order to make it.
So when you have cognitive behavioral
therapy and you have randomized control
and you have a control group, did
you just give him shitty therapy?
[inaudible] wait,
we need to get a therapist on here to
give you the answer that cause I don't
know the answer. You've gone to
therapy yourself. I have. Yeah.
Did you do that to examine
this? Um, I, you know, I,
I mainly went into it with,
for the meditation part
[inaudible] to try and uh,
calm some of my restlessness.
Has writing and all this study that
you had to do to write these books,
has that enhanced you got me that you
have much more of an understanding about
what's at play than the
average person does? Well,
you know, I, again,
it's kind of like the patient who's
reading the emotional brand with the
therapists.
I think by writing those books I learn a
lot and it helps me see things and that
doesn't necessarily help
me lead my life any better.
But I think I understand it a
better, but no self, no fear. Yeah.
Well no self, no fear
means that you have to be,
you have to have this auto
Noetic consciousness ability
in order to be afraid.
And that is a special human quality.
The ability to put yourself in the moment,
in your past and in your future. Um,
if it's not you that's going
to be harmed by that snake,
then you don't have to worry
about what it's gonna do to you.
So if you are a part of it, then
you worry and it becomes, you know,
it's an emotion when you're
involved. So I think emotions,
this is a crazy idea that's in the
book that emotions didn't arise through
natural selection. Really.
Wow. That the idea that
they, um,
were byproducts of other
capacities that came along.
First you had some kind of crude language
that enabled this hierarchical and
relational reason to
jump across, you know,
language gave you categories
to like conceptualize things.
Hierarchical reasoning allowed you
to jump across those categories. Um,
and those kinds of things allow you to
conceptualize yourself as an entity with
an experience.
So you had to have a self that could
do that kind of reasoning and um,
uh, across those conceptual categories.
And that is what enabled on emotion,
the ability to put yourself
into a significant situation.
So now that it's here, now that
we have, once emotions are there,
then they become selected, but they
weren't selected by, for example,
the amygdala having evolved
to be the fear center.
And we inherited that
from animals. You know,
animals probably have some kinds of
experiences, but it's scientifically,
it's very hard to know what they have
really known. Like dogs have emotions,
right? Dog dogs get happy.
You see their behavior, right?
But I'm not saying they aren't, but
scientifically you can't measure that.
Right?
But if you have a dog and you come home
and he's so excited to see you in his
run around circles, that seems
very emotional. Well akin. Yeah,
but I don't said, let's talk about
the brain for a second. Okay.
So the parts of the brain circuits in
the brain that are involved in this kind
of auto Noetic emotion that I'm talking
about, this self involved in motion,
that's so human, uh,
such a human quality, um,
to I w the part of the brain
that I think is important,
and this is still hypothesis
is not a fact, uh,
is something called the
frontal poles. Very,
very front part of the prefrontal cortex.
That region is unique to
the human brain. No other,
not even another ape has that. Now,
other parts of the prefrontal cortex
are present in other primates.
All of the primates, but
not in any other mammal.
So if we can figure out in the human
brain what that frontal pole does and what
that other part, that all primary tab do,
then that gives us an anchor for
speculating about what other primates,
what kinds of experience
other primates have given,
what those parts of the brain enabling us.
And that would allow us to then extract
what other mammals don't have that we
have because they don't have those
parts of the brain. So it's a,
it's a kind of, you know,
you use of the brain to tell us some
things about what might exist in other
animals, but there's no way to ask
a dog what's on your mind, right.
In measure the brain with an FMR eye or
something along those lines where you
get a reading of. But that's not a,
an answer. I mean, it's Carlot, right?
So a human, like, I can, you know,
if you asked me, uh,
is there a pin here on
the table? I say, yes,
I can respond verbally
or I can point to it. Um,
but, uh, when I'm responding verbally,
I can only do that for
something I'm conscious of.
I can't respond to something
I'm unconscious of by naming it,
follow. The other animals can
only respond non-verbally,
so they don't have that other kind
of response that is only reflecting a
conscious state. So I'm not
saying they don't have anything,
but scientifically it's very hard to,
to know what they have and the fact
that we can study it. We know in,
for example,
fear that the fear itself probably
doesn't depend on the amygdala,
but the, all the behavior
that we see does,
makes us have to be cautious about
observing behaviors that look like they're
based on fear, love, and all these other
emotions when we can't really know.
Because we can't measure that. Well,
I mean, it's a tough problem. Again,
I'm not saying it's not there. It's
just like scientifically, you know,
you have to, you have to be
stretched. The evidence. Yes. Yeah.
You have to know now measuring
it in humans is, I mean,
there's this concept of people,
I'm an emotional person. You know,
I'm emotional, like people I get
emotional, like people love to say. Yeah,
those, those kinds of things. What is it
possible to measure varying degrees of
emotional response in terms of like how
it's affecting a person physiologically,
whether or not these emotional responses
are physiological or whether you've
gone down a well-groomed psychological
path that you've been sort of
participating in your whole life so
that you have these sort of triggers.
This happens and then up I'm gonna, I'm
gonna start crying. This happens up.
I'm going to get angry.
And people sort of fall into those
paths without self-reflection,
without this ability to be
objective and introspective and go,
why am I reacting this way? Like what?
Maybe you should stop being so emotional,
Joe. Right? Anybody ever say that?
Uh, I guess my wife to say, well
what does that mean? Like what,
you know what I mean? Like the, this,
the varying degrees of emotional
response and whether or not those are
beneficial or whether or not they just
detract from your experience or inhibit
your, your ability to be
productive. So, you know, I,
it really nailed a lot of interesting
stuff in there and I, um, you know,
it's very kind of deep analysis
of, of what's going on.
So the problem is that our
language is so bad that,
um, all of these terms that we have,
we borrow from what's called folk wisdom
or folk psychology. You know, the,
they've come through the ages and this
is true in every aspect of science that
you have folk terms,
folk physics becomes real physics
and then the folk stuff goes away.
Folk biology becomes real biology and
then, you know, the folk stuff goes away.
But in psychology,
the folk stuff never goes away because
we always experienced the folk aspect of
it. When we have a conscious experience,
that's what our conscious minds is,
our folk psychology of ourselves
and of others and of other animals.
But the, um, um,
underneath that is the part that we can
get rid of the folk psychology because
we can understand how behavior is control,
how these physiological responses are
control and ain't because, you know,
we've had fears causing it, you
know, but when you're afraid,
you're almost always running from
the bear and feeling fear. But,
and, and so you assume that when
you're running from the bear,
fear is what causes you to run.
But fear is not the answer.
Fear is your awareness that all that
should is happening to you. [inaudible]
but also the, the ability to
contemplate the consequences, right?
Yeah. Yeah. Like this is
where it's going to get me,
he's going to Amy and so it's
all that's all, you know,
one interpretation after another
running forward. But no self, no fear.
That's no possible either. Right.
Well if that, I mean you need
the self to be afraid. Yeah.
So I mean that's your, and
to be consciously afraid,
but you can react to danger without the
self. And that's what, yeah, that's key.
You,
you find yourself freezing or you're
walking in New York city and you jumped
back in, the bus goes flying
by. So you've reacted to danger.
But only afterwards do you feel fear
when you cognitively become aware that
that's happened? Well and
that sort of a situation,
but in a situation like we are walking
down a dark alley and then you see some
guy who seems to be following you,
you're like, Oh boy. Yeah. So now you're,
you're in a situation where you're
in a potentially dangerous situation.
So now you're anxious about
what's going to happen.
So you're not starting with theory,
starting with things side it worry
about what's going to happen. Nothing.
There's nothing there that's made you,
but then one of the ramps it up says,
Hey Joe, yeah, come over here man. I'd
like to borrow some money from you.
And you're like, gosh, shit
sounds fear is that fear.
Now you've got a specific threat
and yeah, so you now you're,
and then that's going to
morph into another anxiety
about what the hell is this
guy gonna do to me? Right. So,
but all of that, you know, the,
the dark alleyway is gonna go into your
brain and trigger your muscle tension,
your heart to race and so forth.
And the dark alley is going to go to
your cortex and you're going to be
interpreting the fact that you're in a
dark alley and your heart is racing in
terms of being anxious and
fearful and all of that.
But they're happening
separately. It's not one bundle.
It's like separate things in the brain.
And once we understand that, it becomes,
I think a much easier problem how to
approach problems. If you're in anxiety,
you've got to separately treat the
behavior and the physiology from the
conscious thoughts. And
in between those two,
you also got to change the cognitions
that underlie the conscious experience.
But also the cognitions can
trigger behavior. So, you know,
one of the things we've,
uh, we've proposed a, I
propose this in my last book,
a anxious was a kind of test
program for exploring this where,
uh, be kind of a three part three
step program. Um, first you would,
you'd have to do it with something
simple like the spider phobic of what?
A spider phobic or a snake phobia. Okay.
So you would do exposure
therapy subliminally that
means your limit only present
the picture of a snake or the spider
so fast that the conscious mind doesn't
know it's there. So like those old uh,
hungry eat popcorn things. Movies. Yup.
And that's a very common
technique in psychology.
So they would show you a film and there'd
be one or two frames of a spider if
you had a rock or just a picture, you
know, but it could be a film. Yeah. Okay.
And uh, but it would have to go
very fast in the film. So it would,
so with the picture you had just
presented re really quickly and um,
cause you know, normally if
you show a spider phobic, uh,
try to do exposure therapy,
they don't want to do it cause I don't
want to deal with spiders, but they,
they,
their conscious mind doesn't know what's
happening cause it's going through
subliminally. So the Migdal
is being tamed by the exposure
and now they can look at the
picture without, you know,
the body re reacting. They're
not jumping, they're not,
the heart isn't racing because
the Migdal has been turned off.
So all of those body
responses I've calmed down.
So now the person could kind of go,
some undergo some cognitive change
about looking at spiders and so forth.
And then finally, once
you've done those two steps,
the brain's ready for talk therapy and
meditation and other kinds of mindfulness
approaches. Uh, because all of the,
the impediments to all that had been put
aside by this, these first two steps.
So was anybody ever like
officially cured someone,
a Veracode phobia or video field
of video phobia or you know,
fear of snakes or spiders? Like those are,
they'll seem to almost like deep-seated
genetic fears while the
we, I mean our ancestors,
yes. Had a snake and what they
vary, which is what's weird,
the ancestors certainly
experienced venomous snakes and,
but there's something about,
some people have of almost illogical
reaction to it that it's often been
speculated that this is some sort of
a genetic memory of someone perhaps in
their ancestry lines surviving a snake
attack or losing someone to a snake.
It's more the, you know,
turns out that the, um,
it's more about the ability to rapidly
learn about those kinds of dangers than
to innately respond. Hmm.
So there seems to be,
it's called prepared learning.
So you have an evolutionarily based thing
that's with you that everyone has some
version of. But you know, it varies
from individual to individual.
And then some people, um,
are prone to rapidly learn that either
because of other experiences or because
of their particular genetic makeup.
And so they tend to go down the road of,
of acquiring these kinds of phobias now.
So it's the problem with treating
that by just extinguishing it,
uh, through exposure is that the, um, uh,
extinction is always impermanent. If you,
once you've been reduced
and nothing is wrong,
this is true in a rad or person.
Let's say the rat has been given a tone
that's been paired with a shock and then
it hears the tone 20 or 30
times stopped responding.
But then if it goes back in the room
or the chamber where the shock had
occurred,
the tone will again bring it elicited
in a spider phobic returns to the place
where he or she was bitten by a spider
or a place where spiders have supposed to
be present, it can come
back. So these are imperfect,
temporary solutions. They're
not enough. Um, and uh,
that's why I mean they're called,
uh, these are called, you know,
reinstatement and things like that
because like they popped back up.
So maybe medications can help
tamp that down a bit. So,
uh, medications are useful in,
in that sense of being able to control
the behavior and the physiology.
But less so in terms of changing
the mental state. Because, you know,
how could you possibly design a medication
that would know how to change the
content, have a, a mental state
that seems like an impossible task.
And that's what you want to do. You
don't want to change all mental States,
right? You want to change the one
content, you know, I'm afraid of spiders.
Yeah. Oh, it's,
it's so fascinating though,
how people vary so widely in their,
their reaction to certain fears or to
certain things that could induce fear,
whether it's dogs
or you know, whatever irrational
thing that people have. The,
the source of that is
really often speculated that
there's like some sort of a
genetic component to it. Do you
buy into that? So let's say,
let's say that, you know, in
any kind of situation like that,
there are multiple systems in the
brain that are going to be involved.
We're going to isolate the amygdala as
hypothetical part of that system that is
detecting and responding to the stimulus.
So we're going to go into the amygdala
and focus on one little part of it.
Uh, it's called the lateral
nucleus. That doesn't matter,
but it's the part that gets the
input from the outside world.
So that is the gateway into the
amygdala. So now let's talk about,
let's say it's got, I don't know,
100,000 cells and neurons. Um,
and um,
each of those neurons is
going to have a bell curve
that's based on the genes that made that
cell and whatever kinds of electrical
signals it's had throughout
the life of the organism.
So you're gonna have a hundred
thousand bell curves, you know,
various degrees that when the
stimulus comes in, those cells that,
that are activated,
their little bell curves are going to
determine how much they respond to that.
And that's going to propagate to other
cells that have their own bell KERS in
areas and so on down the line that what
happens at the level of behavior is a
very complicated kind of summation of
all those bell curves of all those cells
that happen to be activated. So it's not
like, you know, one thing is progress.
It's not like a brain areas program.
It's all about what's happened
at those specific cells,
both through genetics and experience.
So we often kind of oversimplified
things by thinking, well,
there's a gene or an area
that has inherited that thing.
When you think of human beings and you
think of what we used to be when we're
some sort of a lower hominid
and now what we are now,
and you think of all these various
components that are at play, do you,
do you ever try to imagine what a human
of a thousand years or 10,000 or a
hundred thousand years from
now we'll be like, Oh, the,
they're going to be different.
You know, we're not,
every organism is in
constant change. You know,
the racial mixing, uh,
interbreeding happens. Um,
and so I end up mutations,
random mutations, uh,
we were living longer. And so, you
know, that's creating, uh, meat.
People are having babies later.
That will change a lot of stuff.
So we're gonna be a different, uh, thing.
And at some point we may split out
into a whole new kind of a human.
The thing about people
having babies older, I mean,
there's certainly
physical limitations, uh,
when people start having babies
older. But on the plus side,
you're dealing with someone that
has a lot more life experiences.
It's raising a child. Yeah.
You know, versus, uh, you know,
my mom had me when she was
20, 21, you know, what do you,
what the fuck do you know when
you're 21, you don't know much,
but if you're a woman who has a child
when you're 40, well, Hey, that's a,
a rich life of a lot of experiences and
maybe you can impart some of that wisdom
to your child. Yeah. And look
at things in a different way.
And maybe that in turn will raise a
child that's more balanced. You know,
I'm talking out of my area
here, but I, I think that, um,
probably, you know,
the eggs sit around for a long time and
I don't know what the effect of aging on
the egg is. Mm. Uh, I
just don't know. Well,
there's also a big factor with the
male sperm, the male sperm. Yes.
They thinking that's one of the
main contributors to autism.
Schizophrenia is supposedly a, uh,
I've heard, uh, that, you know,
older fathers are more likely to have
male sons that are schizophrenia.
Yeah, that makes sense. That is a
fact, but I've heard that, well,
it all makes sense that there'd
be some glitches in the matrix.
I maybe we're not supposed to
live that long, are we not?
But what are your thoughts on people
that are trying to live longer and trying
to sort of squeeze out as much time as
they can on this rock? I don't know.
It's like I see a lot of old people that
just don't want to live anymore and I
understand that you know, that
your body starts falling apart.
Your mind is going, what's the point
at that point? Yeah, I get that.
But what about the people that
can keep it together? Yeah.
I guess if you keep it together,
you'd want to like, you know, okay,
let's just go as far as we can. Let's go
to the moon and, uh, go to Mars. Well,
pharmacological solutions too. I mean if,
if there was some sort of
a genetic component that
they identified to aging and
they gave the option
to reverse the process,
would you participate or do you like it?
Do you like the finite nature
of this existence? I do.
I think so. It's like I
knew you were going to and
I think, uh, I don't, I'm not,
I take certain medications,
but, uh,
I'd rather just live as most of my
life is as possible without them.
So what medications do you take?
Blood pressure and mainly blood
pressure stuff. Yeah. Do you exercise?
Not enough. That's out yet.
They got a big affect on anxiety
and a big effect on just this,
a general alleviation of axed.
So that's a good example of
something I know I should do. Yeah.
Is that a discipline issue? Uh,
I used to be kind of disciplined,
but what happened, I've been
using it a lot too. Uh, you know,
to do things like, uh,
I really want to do like
writing or making music.
And so those are the things that kinda,
I know I should like do the exercise too
so I can do more of that longer. Yeah.
You think you have a finite
amount of discipline? Um,
possibly each person has it, you know,
the find that has that sort of uh,
anxiety quotient, that
discipline quotient to,
let me kinda, you probably can work
that like a muscle and thought,
imagine you can, yeah. Yeah. You
could become something different.
Me and my friends have this thing that
we did last year called sober October or
the entire month, you know,
no alcohol, no marijuana,
no drugs and crazy exercise.
Like last year we had a competition to
see like who could exercise the most.
We wore these heart rate
monitors and we measured points.
Like you get a certain amount of points
at 80% of your max heart rate per
minute. What my point is,
one of the things that I got out
of this and we all got out of it,
we all talked about it cause we were
exercising hours and hours a day,
an incredible alleviation
of anxiety. Incredible.
Like to the point where
I exercise regularly,
but I don't exercise at that level
that that level that we were doing,
cause we were in this competition
was really a lot of cardio.
But my God, that runner's
high is real. I felt amazing.
I mean I felt like so good all the time.
The alleviation of anx was unlike
anything. The internal chatter. Yeah.
That sort of can fuck with your head.
Yeah. That just didn't exist anymore.
Well I think that that's wonderful that
you're saying that because you have so
many followers and I think that's such
fantastic information to convey to them.
It is. And it's so available to all of us.
I mean anybody that can move
their body can experience this.
And I don't recommend what we did
cause we were working out five hours,
six hours a day. You know, I'd walk,
I live in New York so I walk a lot.
That's great. Yeah.
Right. You have to. Yes.
But I mean just that alone is, it's,
there's many people that don't walk.
You know, you just sit here
and then you move to that spot.
You sit there and you get in the car
and you sit there, get on the train,
he'd sit there and there's very little
use of the body and the body starts to
atrophy. Yup.
By pumping that blood through the system
and cleaning out the pipes and getting
that air into the lungs and forcing
yourself to move when it's over,
you feel better. Breathing better
and feel it. Right. I'm imagining it.
Imagining this exercise. Um, what
do you take? What about nature?
Do you take any time in nature at
all? Do you go to central park? Oh,
well we have a house up in Sullivan
County in the Catskills. Oh, that's nice.
Yeah. How often do you get
a chance to get out there?
We spend a lot of time there in
the summer. Oh, that's great.
And do you feel better when you're up
there? Yeah, definitely. Interesting.
Right? Yeah. It takes a couple of days
to like, you know, get into the rhythm.
Yeah. But then it's good. But once
you do, do you ever think, man,
what the fuck am I doing
living in Manhattan where
all these buildings that you
know, my wife for not shooting, my
wife's a new Yorker, so I'm by birth,
so I'm a week there. We need to go in and
then we want to come back. My friend
Jeff has a, a, a place on fire Island.
It's a beautiful place. Beautiful.
And he lives in Manhattan as well.
But he says like as he's gotten
older, but the urine Bogan. Yeah.
He says as he's gotten
older, he really don't,
doesn't think that he could live in
Manhattan anymore if it wasn't for this
ability to escape and go
somewhere and just, ah,
wake up in the morning and look out, see
the ocean, having a cup of coffee. Ah,
moving to Brooklyn was kind of like
that. Getting out of Manhattan. Yeah.
If you don't live in New York,
that may not make a lot of sense to
you and the people with differences.
You know,
Manhattan is just like this super
charged all the time and it's not a,
it's not a try thing. It's, you know,
it's, it's a true thing that you,
once you get out of Manhattan,
everything is just a notch down. Yeah.
And I've done step off the subway and
you kinda feel this a little bit more
relaxed. Do you think that's cause
Brooklyn, I mean, that's just speculative,
but there's still a lot of
people in Brooklyn. Yeah.
But there's no skyscrapers.
Phew. I mean, there's starting to
be lots of tall buildings and stuff,
but once I got the tall building in
Brooklyn, 30 30 right. Residences.
You know what's Manhattan? Like eighties,
there's like eighties and nineties.
Yeah. There's some giant buildings.
I'd looked out the other day, a,
I guess from the airplane and there's
something in North Manhattan that looks
like it's way above the empire
state building in terms of size.
I don't know what that is.
Have you thought about
that existence? Like, um,
in terms of like how unnatural
it is and how recent it is,
this ability to jam untold millions
of how many people are in Manhattan?
Oh boy. You know,
I have no idea that like I think 8
million or something in York city,
but [inaudible] line then
of course computers as well.
So 8 million plus all the people that
come in from different places to work
there and just stuffed into an incredibly
small area and stacked on top of each
other. Yeah.
That has gotta be a completely new
psychological state for the human animal.
Right. Yeah. There was just, I remember
when I first got into, um, psychology,
I was reading something about
something called a behavioral sync. Um,
it was about
how rats living in an
impoverished environment under
highly crowded conditions,
their behavioral repertoire sort of like
diminished a lot. So I think that was,
you know,
sort of used to kind of challenge urban
living and to blame a lot of urban decay
in the 70s, uh, on, uh, I don't think
it was necessarily a good idea, but,
uh, it was kind of a,
a way to explain some things that I think
it wasn't really good at explaining.
Yeah. It's true that that the people do
live under fairly crowded conditions.
But um, that's,
you can't explain everything in
terms of very simple processes.
Are you aware of those studies that
they did where they set cameras up on
streets and they set them distance
apart and they measured footsteps,
how fast people walked and then
they measured the way people talk,
how many syllables and how
many sentences they can get in,
in a certain amount of
time. And through uh,
measuring footsteps and how fast
people walked and the way they talked,
they could accurately determine how
big the city was that they live now.
How much they, yeah, they,
they get accurately figure out whether
or not they lived in a high population
density,
whether or not they lived in a small
town by the way they talked and the way
they walk. It's interesting that there's
a profound effect. I have a call,
I used to have a colleague at NYU
named John barge is that Yale man.
And he used to do these studies where
he would, he was a social psychologist.
He would have people come in,
students come into the lab and
take these letters and they were
like scrambled and he'd have to like,
they'd have to unscramble them into sense.
I guess it was words and you'd have
to unscramble them and put them into a
sentence.
And if the unscramble sentence was
about being older and elder him,
anything about being
elderly and uh, age, um,
it would take the students longer to
walk down the hallway to get to the
elevator afterwards as this like
activating this kind of schema of,
of aging that top-down had some kind
of a effect on the way you walk that.
Well, that makes sense.
And you do see what's really interesting
to me is when you see the differences
between people who are the same age,
who behave and think very differently.
And I always wonder how
much of that is biological,
how much of that a psychological,
how much of that is like, well,
this person just has a better genetic
makeup, you know? And so they've,
you know, in their 50s they
still have tons of energy,
whereas this person maybe has shit,
makeup and bad lifestyle choices and
they look like what we considered,
you know, an old man when we
were younger. Right? Well,
I mean we're also complicated and there's
so many factors that go into shaping
how we end up at any point in our life.
Where do you think selfishness came
from? Auto Noetic consciousness.
So that's this ability to put
yourself into an experience,
which as I said earlier,
is responsible for our greatest
achievements as a species,
but also is what we'll
potentially do as sin.
It allows us to not only
envision a world in which,
you know, we can be self
less self, you know,
not selfish but help others,
but also how to exclude others.
And um, it, I think it's a natural,
basic animal instinct to, uh, stay alive.
Obviously, you know, we've, uh,
Richard Dawkins said the
theory of the selfish gene, uh,
animals are incredibly selfish and you
know, their struggle for existence.
So that kind of, um, automatic
selfishness is there.
But what the auto Noetic mind allows
us to do is to be intentionally,
willfully selfish,
to allow us to choose
to do these things, uh,
for our own personal good.
For example, I think that the,
the auto neurotic human human mind is
the only entity in the history of life
that's been ever to put the
organism that we're talking about.
The conscious mind being a small part
of the what's going on in the cortex to
put all of the rest of the brain and all
of the body at risk for the simple sake
of a thrill. Mountain
climbing, um, you know,
swimming in shark infested waters
are taking drugs at dangerous levels.
Um,
no other organism can commit suicide in
the sense of intentionally planning to
put an end to an entity that
it knows has the possible end.
So our conscious minds are special,
uh, in good ways and bad ways.
The conscious mind that seeks thrills.
What do you think is the root of that?
Like I've always wondered like why certain
people are drawn to doing like flips
on motorcycles or certain people are
drawn to climbing mountains with no ropes.
Like, what do you think that is?
And I'm just guessing,
I don't really know,
but I think that we each have
these kind of physiological,
uh, States that, that we
try to maintain. You know,
some kids are homeostatic
levels are, are different. Um,
and some people need a little more
adrenaline or a little more, um,
you know, I hate to use adrenaline
and a kind of a, um, cheap way of,
you know, just saying it's just more
of a rusher kind of body activity.
Um, because all of that also affects
the brain. Um, and so consciously,
um, you strive, you may go looking for
those kinds of things to get the rush.
Um, and it's, uh,
you know, it's, uh,
it's sort of on the spectrum of
addiction in a sense where you need that
physiological change that the
drug induces. But, you know,
we also have addictions in our lives
that are habits and things that, uh,
that we develop and pursue that
aren't necessarily good for us,
but that we kind of feel compelled to do.
Do you know who Alex
Honnold is? Yeah, yeah.
I've had him on the podcast a couple
of times and every time I talked to my
hands started getting sweaty.
I get so nervous for folks who
don't know who we're talking about,
he's a the probably the most famous
free solo climber in the world and he
climbed these seemingly impossible
mountains with no ropes.
And there's video of him doing it live.
His drone footage of him climbing these
peaks and my hands just pouring sweat.
But I said watch it. But
when I talked to him,
what's really interesting is he's a calm,
rational,
intelligent man who's
very thoughtful and he's,
he's a very kind guy. He's, he
doesn't seem like some, you know,
I think of when I think of someone who
likes to do flips off with a motorcycle
or do radical, I think of some
crazy wild thrill seekers. Some,
some do to just needs to constantly,
or a woman who needs to
be constantly freaked out.
He's not that guy. And
when he describes it,
what's really interesting is he
goes, it's very mellow. He's like,
if there's any, if there's
a really a thrilled,
I've done something horribly wrong.
Like the real thrills are so scary
because it means you're about to die.
So he's, instead of getting the
thrill, he's getting that piece.
Yeah. But he's getting a piece from
putting himself in extremely risky.
And there's also the thing of other
people praising you for your risk-taking,
which is an odd thing about humans and
they've shown through natural, uh, well,
there's a natural selection aspect of it
with females and mates that females are
attracted to men that do those crazy
things and take crazy risks for some
strange reason, whether it's some
sort of a remnant of our ancient past,
like that thrill seeking man
has got not going to be a,
he's not going to shy away from combat.
He will protect our children or
something like that. Right? Yeah. I mean,
there's a lot of evolutionary
psychology. Yeah.
You know that a lot of that is
speculative. Of course, of course.
But it's the thrill seeker is a,
that's why it's one of the weirder things.
When everything's great and you have
plenty of food and you live in cities and
like, okay, look, I'm not
getting enough juice here. Yeah.
I'm going to have to learn how to
hand gliders, you know, and yeah,
some people may do it for
attention or yes. Yeah.
The things people do for attention. Um,
creativity is a,
that debt to me is one of
the more interesting aspects
of being a human being.
So our ability to create things
and our desire to create things.
And in a way that's also
along the same lines, right,
because you're getting
rewarded for it. Well,
probably. Yeah.
So I mean all of these things are,
as a child as is developing and growing
up and passing through different kinds
of situations in life, um,
I think a lot of stuff happens
kind of randomly, you know,
so that the child may do something
that someone views as creative.
And so as you said, the
child is rewarded for that.
So then that allows them to
figure out what, you know,
explore kind of how they did that
and, and maybe continued to do it,
but other people may simply have
mindset go in that direction,
um, on their own where it's a, as
we talked about earlier, their,
their thoughts are able to jump
across conceptual categories and,
and, uh,
sort of transcend those categories into
new completely new ideas and so forth.
And, you know, I don't think we
know how the brain does that at all.
That's a very good
question for the future,
but it's not something we have a great
deal of understanding of. Uh, now,
I mean, there could be an era of research
on it that I just don't know about it.
It's a big field. Um, but, uh,
I certainly don't know the answer
to how creativity comes about. Well,
it's interesting too. Creativity has a,
a reward system built in for
the person who creates, even,
even without recognition from others,
there's some fundamentally satisfying
feeling of creating something.
It's fun. Yeah. Why do you think that is?
Well, novelty is rewarding, not
reinforcing, you know, it's,
uh, and certainly creativity is novelty.
It's like anything that is novel,
uh, that you do has a kind of, you know,
charge effect to it, I would think.
Yeah. I mean, it's,
people like you who study this stuff to
me are so important because most of us
are just banging into the walls just
trying to figure out why we do what we do
and to have an ability to understand the
scientific explanations for the various
things that are at play. It's, it's so,
it's so critical because
you can kind of like,
almost not necessarily stop the process,
but at least be aware of
it while it's going down.
Is that part of what you wanted
to do when you were riding?
Well, I wanna thank you for, um, you
know, crediting me for that, but the, um,
you know, a lot of what
we've been talking about,
we've just been having a conversation.
My work is very rather limited and all,
I don't work on creativity and
all these things. So I'm kind of,
you work on the way the mind
works I work on, yeah. I mean, um,
I think about how the word the mind works,
but I work on how the brain
detects in response to danger. Uh,
so that allows me to go back to my early
work on consciousness and to bring it
in and layer it on top of all that
other stuff. But yeah, it's, um,
you know, I, I get tremendous, uh,
value out of sitting there and
because when you start a book,
in my case, I think this is
probably true of many people.
You don't have no idea how you're
gonna get to the end. You know,
you have a beginning and
you just see where it goes.
So this idea of writing a proposal that
lays out the whole thing to me doesn't
work because you just don't
know where it's going. And, um,
the fun part is getting to the
end, the brain reacting to danger.
Do you, did you,
did you do any interviews with people
who are soldiers or interview fighters or
people that are involved in extreme
activities that yeah, no, I haven't,
uh, I haven't done a
lot of interviews. Um,
I mean I have talked to people
like that and um, you know,
every individual cases are interesting
because they give you stuff but it's not
data. So the data you have
to go out and collect. Yeah.
What do you got there for notes?
You got a pile notes or just, Oh,
I don't know what to discuss.
Um, I just thought, uh,
this brought this,
I think we covered most
of what I wanna say. Yeah.
They make those as not a fear center.
Behavior is not primarily a tool of
the mind. It's a tool of survival.
We think we know why we do the
things we do and others do them,
but we don't really, because we,
our conscious mind is not privy to all
of the things that the body and brain are
doing now.
When you wanted to examine danger and
you want to examine the mind and how it
reacts to danger and
fear and threats. What,
what were you trying to
get out of this? Well,
I started out thinking this was
a way to study emotion. And um,
at the time I, you know,
I'd been studying these,
these a human patients with the split
brain surgery and can you explain that,
cause you, you glossed over that earlier.
But the split brain surgery
is a alleviation of epilepsy.
It's a way to control epilepsy. The
can't be controlled in any other way.
Medication's not working.
So you have like young kids,
teenagers that have lived
most of their life, uh,
this paralyzed by epilepsy and
not being able to lead a life.
Uh, there was one patient to basically
his parents constantly having to hold him
down on a mattress. He
was seizing so often. So,
and this is not, this is only done in a,
in a very extreme set of conditions
and it's not done that much anymore.
But when it's done, it's, um,
the connections between the two sides
of the brain are, are separated.
So information on one side doesn't cross
over to the other. Do they do that? Uh,
they open up the skull,
pulled the two, you know,
you've got kind of two loaves of bread
sitting next to each other and they're
connected by threads, which
are axons that go between them.
And so you pull apart here and you can
see where those axons are and when you
opened up
from the top, so imagine
like a hot dog bun. Okay. Uh,
and so you opened it up at the top and
you can look down in the center and
imagine that there was
like a bunch of, uh,
wires crossing between
the two sides of the bun.
So those wires would then
be surgically sectioned.
And so now you end up with
two sides of the brain,
separate and independent. So
typically languages on the left side,
so you can talk to that side. The
right side doesn't have language. Um,
so you have to ask, well, what can it do?
So if you present a stimulus that
only the right hemisphere sees,
and you do that by flashing, uh, uh,
say a picture of an Apple
on the left side of space,
cause everything to the left of center
goes to the right hemisphere and
everything to the right of center
goes to the left hemisphere.
So you send a stimulus to the
right hemisphere and you say,
what did you see?
And the left atmosphere answers cause
that's where the languages, he says,
I didn't see anything. So okay.
You said reach into this bag and see
what's in there. The right hand goes in,
that's connected to the left hemisphere.
Can't find it. The left hand goes in,
connected to the right hemisphere,
that which saw the Apple,
it pulls out the Apple. Wow.
So the right hemisphere has information
that the left hemisphere can't talk
about. What is life like for people
once they've done that operation? Um,
while slowly it,
the left hemisphere kind of comes
to dominate again. And uh, the uh,
you know, they, they come to live with
it. And how does it prevent seizures?
Well, the, the folklore of it, I
don't know if this is actually true,
but what is often said is that it prevents
the seizures from jumping back and
forth, uh, and having,
you know, because the, um,
the electrical activity jumping back
and forth sort of gets into kind of an
endless loop that can't stop but cutting
that isolates the seizures in the two
hemispheres and makes each
one more controllable by
taking the medication Jesus.
So managing the, being the first guy
to try that out. I've got an idea.
Let your brain like a hot dog man. So, um,
but what we were interested in in these
patients that we were studying, my,
this was my mentor Michael
Khazanah gun. Um, and I were,
we're studying these at a
Dartmouth medical school.
We were at Stonybrook out on long Island.
We would drive up to Dartmouth
to see these patients. Um, was,
how does the left hemisphere cope with
the fact that the right hemisphere is
performed to behavior? That the it,
the left hemisphere that you talk
to didn't come. And so we would,
you know, putting information in the
right hemisphere, the guy would stand up.
Why is that? Why'd you do that?
I needed to stretch or you know,
scratch his hands or I had an itch
so I needed to, to scratch it.
And so time after time
they left hemisphere would
generate a narrative that made
its behavior. Makes sense. Oh wow.
So that's why I got interested in how
non-conscious systems would be generating
behaviors that we generate
narratives to explain.
Because at the time
that we were doing this,
the idea of cognitive
dissonance was very popular.
And what that means is that
when cognitively when you
do something behaviorally
that is incongruent with
what you cognitively know,
it's disturbing. It causes dissonance.
And so you have to engage in some
kind of dissonance reduction.
So our hypothesis was these narratives
that the left hemisphere is generating
about right hemisphere
behaviors was a way of,
of the left hemispheres
conscious mind. Um,
kinda keeping it all together. That
consciousness thinks that it's in charge,
that you know, the brain and
body are, it's, you know, it's a,
it's the S the the control center
and everything else is there to,
to satisfy its whims.
And so it generates these narratives
to keep that sense of unity going even
though it's no longer unified.
That is so fascinating that the brain
tries to seek some sort of an explanation
for the actions that you
provoked right externally.
And that's why I got into emotion cause
well maybe emotion systems produce
these. You got some Jamie,
when I'm looking this up, uh,
alien hand syndrome came up.
Do you know anything about this? I
don't. I'm sorry. Oh, okay. It's a,
there's a long article explaining this
thing called alien hand syndrome and also
known as dr. Strange lo
syndrome picture doc.
Just true explanations are very strange
about people's hands doing something
that they're not explaining it right.
I don't know why I did it. Of the same,
yeah. Do they generate an
explanation when they do that?
It just explains different scenarios.
People who've had like a leg walking
the wrong direction or a sh buttoning up
your shirt with your left hand or right
hand starts unbuttoning that seems
to be like some sort of a neurological
problem. Flip brain patients with,
you know, the right after surgery
when things are really like fucked up.
So girly, it would be like
pulling the pants down with one hand
and pulling them up with the, wow.
There's one patient I saw in
the hospital, the young kid,
the left hand reaches out to grab the
nurse on the ass. Can I say that day?
Yeah. Grab the right and the right
hand is pulling it back. Oh my God.
Oh my God. There's like a physical
struggle. There's like this and you know,
and it all kind of like over time
they don't come back
together, but the son,
they negotiate something
where it's not so dramatic.
The woman who thinks her alien hand wants
her to be a better person. Yeah. See,
I'm thinking these are some
sort of physiologic, yeah,
well it's a what? A crazy to epilepsy.
I know there's other solutions, but
that, that is a last ditch effort.
Yeah. And so for severe,
severe cases, yeah.
And I can't stop done that often to
eventually sort of achieve some sort of a
normalization. Yeah. Um, you know, that
Dave lives,
the kids have lived so long in the state
by the time they get there, they're,
uh, brains change like that, that,
um,
I don't know really ultimately, uh, what,
what became of all of these people because
I, I moved on to other fields and um,
but I, I think in general they
live a, a somewhat better life,
but I doubt they ever live a
completely full normal life. I mean,
how could you after all that,
but I'm really interested in the,
the brain creating these narratives
to explain. Yeah. That's,
there's so many people that do
things like that. Yeah. Right.
They'll try to explain their life away
and give themselves excuses and give
themselves a reasons for behavior.
And one of the things you see with the
more rational people is it's never their
fault. It's always someone else's fault.
But that's the 4 billion year story
that I tell you and how we generate,
how we got to these narratives. That's
what it's all about. Wow. Listen, man,
this is amazing stuff. Um, please
tell everybody your books, um,
where they can get them,
how they can find them.
Are they available in audio
as well, right? Yeah. So the,
the new book is called the
deep history of ourselves,
the 4 billion year story of
how we got conscious brains.
And you can get that on Amazon.
You can get the all the audible on
audible.com. You know, Barnes know,
I think all of the, the major
booksellers have the books.
Last book was anxious. Uh, it
also has an audible version.
I always want it to get like
Christopher Walken to do mine.
Why did you not do it? I didn't do
it. They didn't ask me anything.
I would want you to do
it. It's your work. Right?
I get bummed out when
someone else reads like,
one of the good things about like Pinker
and glad while they read their own
books like a, they've never
offered it to me. You should,
you should demand next to mandate for my,
for my memoir. I'll definitely, uh Oh,
there you go to, well thank
you for being here. I really,
really appreciate it and thanks.
Thanks for all your work.
Did I just say one thing
please? Uh, so sometimes I um,
when I released books I also
released music to go with them.
So anxious had a record with it and a
deep history has some songs of life that
are on the deep history.com website
with Oh, that's cool. So you're,
you are a musician. You were bringing
that up. All right. Yeah. Got,
I've got a couple of bands and a
couple bands. Well, the main band is a,
the MIG delights I make
delights.com. Oh, that's awesome.
Yeah, it's a rock band we play, we
created our own a genre heavy metal
songs about mine and brain and
mental disorders. They're love songs,
but most rock songs
are love songs about mental
disorders anyway. Yes. Yeah.
You just being cystic duo. So we are,
which is a lot easier to get around
without drums and amps and stuff.
We just two acoustic guitars. Awesome.
We play the acoustic versions
of the Migdal Delordes.
All right, well thank you,
Joe. I appreciate you. Thanks for
the fine. Thank you. That's great.